moi je m'intéresse aux arts visuels
j'en fabrique gens regardent les oeuvres
des autres mais aussi je vois des hommes
des jeunes êtres humains en fabriquer
devant moi puisque j'en sais rien au
niveau collégial
il y aurait été tentant de vous
présenter des images et de les commenter
mais j'ai plutôt envie de faire une
expérience presque inverse
vous avez peut-être remarqué en entrant
dans la salle des petits foulards qui
sont fixés sur les dossiers des chaises
je vous inviterai à les prendre
et à les mettre sur vos yeux de vous
bande et le vous boucher le regard j'ai
pensé à ce petit dispositif puisque
parfois pour réfléchir à un objet il
peut être intéressant de le mettre
quelques minutes en veilleuse s'est
excusé moi j'ai la gorge c'est bon alors
voici vous l'avez déjà entendu paraît-il
que nous sommes dans une société de
l'image
il est à peu près incontestable que les
dispositifs de fabrication et de
diffusion des images sont sans précédent
dans l'histoire de l'humanité
ce qu'il faut dire aussi simultanément
sait que c'est sur le plan de la
quantité des images que nous le sommes
simultanément et collectivement nous
nous comportons devant les images comme
ce que j'appelle des icônes aux icônes
aux saveurs images comme des icônes aux
hystériques
c'est à dire que nous voulons voir
nous voulons tous voir et nous voulons
toujours voir la raison en est peut-être
que nous ne comprenons pas toujours bien
comment fonctionnent les images ma
présentation est divisé en quatre
parties
alors je commence rêver nous avons tous
déjà rêver les rêves nous font
expérimenté disons des situations
parfois cocasses inusité parfois aussi
anxiogène
ce qui est intéressant c'est que nous
avons une forme de protection c'est à
dire que si la tension devient trop
forte c'est le réveil c'est ce qui fait
dire à certains psychanalystes que le
rêve c'est comme et j'insiste sur le com
c'est comme de la psychose
une psychose qui serait non pathologique
parce que régulier une forme de
protection
le psychanalyste jean baptiste pontalis
explique à propos du rêve une chose qui
comme moi comme artistes en arts visuels
m'intéresse beaucoup
il dit le rêve est expérimenté comme
quelque chose de visuel le souvenir
qu'on en a très souvent et visuelle mais
il dit c'est un visuel qui est très
particulier c'est un visuel qui est un
partageable puisque nous en sommes le
seul témoin la seule chose qu'on peut
faire
après le rêve si on désire ans le
partager c'est le traduire le traduire
en mots ou en fabriquant d'autres images
comme un film d'un jeune
usée utilisé des images il ya plusieurs
contexte dans lequel la vue et se
désister et c'est contexte où ces
situations engage une relation à l'image
qui peut être très très très différentes
juan nommé 3 la première l'a qualifié de
didactique
quand par exemple on regarde une
émission caractère scientifique et que
nous entendons une narration nous
explique le fonctionnement chimiques de
tels médicaments et que visuellement des
infographistes ont fabriqué des images
très souvent géométrique où on voit des
dix faire rencontrer des triangles et
puis fusionné bon la raison de cette
fabrication d'image elle et pour nous
permettre comme téléspectateur par
exemple de se faire une représentation
simplifiée mais cohérente du dispositif
en fait du phénomène dont il est
question
deuxième exemple un usage disons cultuel
de l'image des pratiques culturelles
cultuelles dans le cadre de culte quand
par exemple des gens qui sont
extrêmement croyants on n'a pas besoin
mais parfois vont se placer devant
certaines images pour leur permettre de
se mettre en situation pour favoriser
par exemple la prière ou le
recueillement etc
on peut parler d'un usage cultuel qui
est très différent de celui que j'ai
nommés précédemment troisième
troisième exemple je dirais un exemple
rhétorique d'utilisation d'image je
simplifie à outrance mais la rhétorique
c'est un peu comme séduire pour
convaincre je refais harissa tout le
secteur de la publicité quand par
exemple le long des autoroutes ou encore
à la télé ou peu importe le support on
est placé devant une image qui essaie de
transformer nos comportements comme par
exemple à celle du poulet acheter des
voitures ou nous sensibiliser sur les
dangers de la conduite automobile homme
en état d'ébriété par exemple ce sont
des usages de l'image qui vise un
changement de comportement 3
voir des images
qu'en est-il de l'art quelles seraient
les usages qui serait relié à la
fabrication d'un tableau ou une
sculpture et installation de spectateur
quel usage on fait quand on se place
devant des oeuvres c'est très différent
de l' usage cultuel c'est très différent
de l'usaj dont didactique qui c'est très
différent de l'usaj que j'ai appelé
rhétorique
évidemment ces catégories peuvent se
sont entrechoquées je dirais deux choses
pour les arts visuels c'était un peu
différent pour d'autres formes d'art
c'est très souvent les oeuvres nous font
entrer dans des mondes nous faut
expérimenter des mondes
la deuxième chose et c'est vraiment très
répandu dans les arts visuels
c'est beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'oeuvres nous font l'enfant nous invite
à réfléchir sur le fait même de regarder
combien devront déconstruire des images
vont les triturer vont les modifier pour
en fait nous montrer quelque chose du
visible d'un peu différent de
l'expérience quotidienne que nous
faisons du visible 4
voir autrement
voir kiss toujours bon de se le rappeler
c'est ce que nous avons de commun avec
les chevreuils avec les perruches avec
les aigles etc
certaines ces animaux ou une acuité
visuelle beaucoup plus grande que la
nôtre
ceci dit jusqu'à preuve du contraire
aucun de ceux ci ne porte un regard sur
les objets je voudrais farissi la
distinction entre voir et regarder
qu'est ce que c'est que regarder
je devais d'abord que regarder ces prend
en fait je dirais essentiellement que
regarder c'est prendre un risque
regardez c'est porter son attention
visuelle sur un objet et simultanément
fabriquer du langage des pensées
intérieures qu'on peut décider de
partager ou pas mais on fabrique de
langage je dirai aussi que voir c'est
prendre un risque puisque c'est prendre
le risque de se transformer
voir c'est ce que m pardon regardez
c'est ce que m c'est s'engager et si
c'est vrai que nous sommes dans une
société de l'image ou risque d'être un
peu radical moi je crois pas que le
regard se porte si bien dans notre
société
la présentation est presque terminée
dans les prochaines minutes
bernard lamarche va vous présenter vous
raconter un moment où peut-être il dira
dans ses mots il ya eu une expérience de
regards qui fut très marquante dans son
parcours très très très marquant dans
son parcours
d'ailleurs sa présentation vous voit
vous inviter à regarder
avant d'enlever vos bandeau je voudrais
vous remercier de votre attention
merci merci martin on a parlé
d'éducation
on a parlé de décrochage je vous parlais
des deux j'ai effectivement vécu une
expérience fascinante il ya maintenant
25 ans 25 ans mène cette année
faites le compte du 18 ans et j'ai
décroché
j'étais à l'époque en informatique de
gestion ou en informatique de gestion
je me voyais là j'étais destiné à
devenir un informaticien j'écrivais des
programmes pour gérer des bibliothèques
on commence comme ça au cégep et
j'allais suivre un cours complémentaire
ce que je vais faire aujourd'hui c'est
vous raconter rapidement parce que
secours ces deux courts longs durée
quand même cinq heures rapidement donc
les deux premiers cours d'histoire de
l'art que j suivi au cégep
ces deux cours d'histoire de l'art
l'homme ont fait abandonner
l'informatique
j'étais même inscrit comme ingénieur
j'étais inscrit au programme de génie
informatique de l'université de montréal
pendant tout un été temps deux semaines
avant de commencer les classes
j'ai tout larguer et le cheval étudie
l'histoire de l'art qu'est ce qui est
arrivé c'est que j'étais marquée par un
professeur on en a parlé
j'ai été marqué par un professeur qui a
changé le cours de ma vie qui m'ont
permis de voir des choses et qui m'ont
permis même de comprendre qu'ils avaient
des choses à voir dont je ne connaissais
même pas l'existence
premier cours d'histoire que j'ai suivi
au cégep
c'est ce que j'ai vu jusque là j'ai
aucune culture visuelle chez nous il y
avait une culture littéraire mamère
lisait énormément mon père écoutait
beaucoup de musique classique mais il y
avait pas de culture visuelle le seul
tableau que je connaissais à l'époque
peut-être sauf la mona lisa que tout le
monde connaît
c'est ce tableau de rembrandt qui
malheureusement n'est même plus se
rendra aujourd'hui qui ont été d
attribuer suite à des recherches
scientifiques
donc ce tableau là était sur ma voix de
couleur quand j'étais petit je vous
l'avais déjà vu sur une boîte de
couleurs la boîte de crayons etc puis
rendra aujourd'hui donc je me l'ont un
peu un peu dépossédé de seul tableau que
je connaissais à l'époque c'est ce que
je vois on est dans un coin
complémentaires donc c'est la société
des nations des gens qui étudiait pour
devenir infirmier des gens qui utilisent
en matériaux composites
donc j'en fais rien je me souviens qu'on
a fait le tour de classe tout le monde
dit d'où il venait
c'est avant de voir ces deux tableaux là
les deux tableaux sont projetés au mur à
l'époque c'était ou à l'écran à l'époque
c'étaient des diapositives maintenant
travailler avec d'autres outils et il
est venu une question la question à mon
sens changé ma vie de tous d'autant plus
qu' on l'avait personne mais alors la
personne vu venir cette question là la
question c'est est qu'est ce qui
apparaît entre les deux tableaux
qu'est ce que pareil entre les deux
tableaux la couleur notamment la couleur
plein de choses on a passé trois heures
12h50 cours de cégep longtemps on a
passé trois heures là dessus on ne peut
arrêter deux secondes on a discuté tout
du long de caisse qui avait pareil comme
ces deux tableaux serait plus par
exemple deux peintres canadiens mais ça
on le savait pas le prof ne l'avait pas
dit quand et l'uscri goff un tableau qui
est dans la collection de winnipeg
rogues gallery patterson et wayne un
pain du 20e siècle
krieg offre un pain du 19e siècle deux
époques sont connaissait l'étape 2
époque complètement différente mais la
question c'est toujours quelque part
entre deux tableaux on en avant par les
deux formats de tableau à l'horizontale
pour comprendre que l'horizontale était
parfaitement adapté aux paysages on est
bien placé dans la région ici parce que
les paysages sont sont vastes et donc on
a pu transposer ça sur le tableau
abstrait qui est aussi horizontale la
couleur le bleu du ciel le bleu du
tableau qui est un quasi monochrome
c'est presque tout bleu mieux quand même
cette ligne orange la couleur orange
celle du coucher de soleil la même d'un
tableau abstrait la courbe des montagnes
je vous laisse compléter dans votre tête
le mouvement du tableau en scène ici de
qingdao c'est-à-dire fraude et les
fraudes et la douane dans notre culture
on lit tous de gauche à droite et donc
on comprend que pour qu'elle ait un
drame fait les clients les bandits
soient déjà passé la douane donc est
déjà triché fallait qu'il soit à gauche
et qu'on lise le tableau de gauche à
droite on continue puisque c'est une
c'est un acquis on veut continuer à lire
le tableau de patterson et one de gauche
à droite dont conçu
ce mouvement qui est arrêtée d'un côté
et qui est infinie de l'autre côté vers
la droite et cetera et cetera et cetera
qu'on est en train de faire c'était
point cours d'histoire ce n'était pas
encore un cours d'histoire dollar c'est
un cours pour nous permettre de
comprendre comment fonctionne une image
c'est un cours de lecture de l'image
tout simplement
on est très on était en train
d'apprendre qu'ils avaient des choses à
voir
on est en train de les nommer ces choses
ces éléments du tableau et surtout on
était en train d'apprendre à regarder
je répète j'en informatique de gestion
j'ai jamais vu ça je comprends pas ce
qui se passe pourtant ça va marquer
pourquoi parce que parce que la réponse
est à ce point là étrange
le premier cours d'histoire de l'art et
que les réponses étaient convaincantes
les réponses étaient clash soutien se
passe quelque chose
deuxième cours d'histoire de l'art
aidons-les tomber dans l'histoire on
était dans la continuité du premier
cours on nous explique en 1917 un
artiste français marcel duchamp a
proposé un urinoir à dans une exposition
de groupe une exposition collective à
new york en 1910 est ce que particulier
c'est qu'on est devant un groupe
d'artistes qui est de et de mécènes et
de gens aimant la culture qui se dit
libéraux au sens politique du terme mais
au sens d'une ouverture d'esprit
la plus totale donc c'est une exposition
où on demande aux artistes d'envoyer ce
qu'ils veulent
y a pas de critère n'y a pas de jugement
ya pas de refus c'est un love est refusé
marcel duchamp qui fait partie des
organisateurs envoyé sous un pseudonyme
richard motte d'une adresse de
philadelphie un urinoir de façon
absolument nous ans mais j'ai pas entrer
là dedans ici il ya intitulé l'urinoir
fontaine je vous laisse imaginer le
reste donc on est devant un concours
artistes et où il ya pas de règles ou on
accepte tout et ça s'est refusé l'oeuvre
n'a jamais été exposée le vt refusé donc
on la connaît par une photographie qui
de façon encore là c'est intéressante
pour j'espère que vous allez trouver la
même chose de moins des potes ont été
publiés dans une revue d'avant-garde de
l'époque s'appelait the blind man
l'homme aveugle on 9e cette enveloppe
jamais existé elles étaient refusés dont
la connaît quarante ans plus tard parce
que marcel duchamp continuer une
carrière tout aussi iconoclaste dans les
gestes qu'il a posés que celui ci est
quarante ans plus tard peut prédire
venus avec sept joueurs donc on est
devant une oeuvre qui a jamais existé
mais tu as changé le cours des choses
tellement vrai que plusieurs années plus
tard à l'époque je suis aux devoirs
comme critique d'art on a pu écrire ce
texte belote à dire qu'on a demandé les
britanniques à l'époque au début du
siècle faisait beaucoup de ces se lever
merci l'un des sondages
merci où il demandait à 500 spécialistes
de nommer les dix oeuvres les plus
marquantes du 20e siècle
l'oeuvre qui était votée la plus
marquante du xxème siècle c'est celle ci
je vous explique dans deux instants
pourquoi sa marque et il faut en dehors
du xxème siècle ça m'a marqué moi j'en
ai fait mon mémoire de maîtrise huit ans
plus tard un mémoire de maîtrise que
portait sur une oeuvre
celle ci est si vous dire que le cours
que j'ai reçu d'ailleurs je dois rendre
mes joues et rendre ses lettres de
noblesse à la personne qui nous la donne
et français une patine au qui était le
professeur à l'époque donc nous a
tellement bien expliqué ce dont il
s'agit c'est que je me suis dit que
j'étais placé devant la chose la plus
étrange monde pour moi à l'époque mais
que plutôt que de la rejeter
je me suis dis parce que c'est la chose
la plus éloignée de tout ce que je
connais je vais aller voir et je suis
tellement les voir que j'en ai fait un
bac maîtrise sur cette voie là j'en ai
fait une carrière et c'est ce que je
fais aujourd'hui j'ai aucun regret
l'informatique de gestion
m'intéresserait plus du tout aujourd'hui
parce que je me nourris maintenant à ce
que les artistes nous proposent qui sont
toujours plus ou moins le plus éloigné
de tout ce qu'on connaît
donc il ya matière à les voir le cours
sur l'oeuvre de duchamp aussi porté sur
les opérations
moi je vous ai dit pour le patin et
wayne intrigue off qui avait dérobé des
similarités son objet que l'artiste a
utilisé qu'il a retournée comme un
sculpteur pour retourner sa matière il
le signe est comme une oeuvre d'art le
déposer sur un socle il ya 10 voici
c'est aussi de leur premier temps 1917
on est dans l'avant-garde mais quand
même ce que duchamp venait de faire
c'est de dire que ce qu'un artiste
choisi comme étant de l'art peut on
devenir suffit qu'on aille voir et
utiliser des opérations signatures
déposées sur un socle les mêmes
opérations que sculpteur traditionnels
pourraient faire c'est d'autant plus que
c'est de la céramique
sauf que le modèle la forme elle est
éduquée par un ingénieur il venait aussi
nous dire que le travail d'un ingénieur
peut être aussi vu d'un point de vue
artistique
c'est tout ça que duchamp venelles y est
attaché pour le plus grand bonheur d'un
étudiant l'époque de 18 ans puis qui
connaît rien de cette nature du monde
ce que duchamp en fait il ya pris un
objet comme on va dire qu'on prend une
photo prendre une photographie c'est
encore plus vrai aujourd'hui on en a
tous dans nos poches en ce moment les
appareils photo ont pas sur le bouton
s'est fait du chant au prix un objet de
séduction était blanc comme on prend des
photos et ça peut devenir aussi un geste
artistique
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on sait
tous que la photographie nous permet de
partager le point de vue de quelqu'un
sur un paysage un objet une personne et
cetera et cetera
c'est partager le regard je prends une
photo je vous la montre je vous partager
ce que j'ai vu ce qui est intéressant
aussi c'est que la photographie c'est
une oeuvre de il yal excoffier d'une
photographe montréalaise c'est que la
photographie nous fait aussi voir ce
qu'on a vu mais peut nous permettre de
voir ce qui est invisible
ici on un espèce d'effet fantomatique
c'est comme si un fantôme est apparu lui
même pour prendre son propre portrait
est ensuite fuir on a capté de la
lumière c'est de la lumière pure et ça
c'est une vieille idée du dix neuvième
siècle alors 19e siècle on a inventé la
photographie
c'était pas comme aujourd'hui et on
pensait aussi que les fantômes étaient
de la lumière
donc on a un objet n apparaît qu un
outil qui captent la lumière
on pense que les fantômes c'est de la
lumière dont ça allait de soi c'est
évident qu'on peut prendre des fantômes
en photo donc la photographie qui se
posent et d'enregistrer tout ce qu'on
voit de façon parfaitement fidèle nous
permet aussi de voir des choses qui sont
de l'ordre de l'invisible fascinant la
même manière qu'eux une peinture comme
celle de pathos ni wayne label groening
orange nous permet de comprendre la
structure d'un paysage tout ce qui est
plus traditionnel on pourra dire à la
limite que lesquin artistes comme
patrick chesnais wayne est revenu sur
des propositions plus ancienne avec un
vocabulaire qui était le sien au moment
où il le fait dans l'est à la fin des
années 60
j'ai eu le plaisir
lachance l'honneur d'avoir quelqu'un
dans mon existence qui m'a permis de
quelques partager avec ses étudiants son
regard des oeuvres qu'elle présentait
donc j'ai appris à voir avec cette
personne là donc ces personnes la
partager avec nous le regard qu'elle
portait sur un objet un objet d'art même
un objet d'art controversées comme
l'urinoir et on sait que là aussi peut
nous faire voir l'invisible à travers
l'art on peut aussi voir des choses qui
sont intangibles
donc on en vient à la conclusion que si
quelqu'un peut partager un regard sur un
objet et que cet objet là par exemple
une photographie peuvent nous faire voir
l'invisible dans les deux cornes états
unis dans une situation où est ce que
des gens s'assoient un professeur
d'histoire de l'art que ça soit une
artiste partage avec nous leurs regards
sur la lumière l'invisible la matière le
politique le social
donc ce qu'ils font ces gens là ceux qui
partagent leurs points de vue avec nous
on appelle ça une proposition on n'est
pas obligé de l'accepter mais je pense
qu'on est obligé ne serait ce que parce
que c'est son ce sont des individus qui
partage avec nous leurs points de vue du
moins regardés et si possible regardé un
certain moment on est au musée des
beaux-arts la nouvelle écosse halifax
devant une oeuvre de jean claude tubize
je suis resté assis devant cette oeuvre
pendant une heure et demie procès de
comprendre comment ça fonctionnait et on
parle de 4 1 ce vingt ans que je fais ce
que je fais dans la vie je me suis assis
devant cette loi parce que je me disais
je suis pas sûr de bien saisir ce que
l'artiste nous cache commun une cache
quelle effervescence des formes autour
de ces grands carrés noirs là qui sont
des 7 à la série à l'époque de jacques
hurtubise qui est un peintre québécois
des black out nous empêcher de voir
précisément on nous empêche endroit nous
permettait de compléter comme vous est
demandé de compléter parfois mes phrases
et parfois mes idées aujourd'hui je suis
resté une heure et demi devant ce
tableau l'as si bien que les gardiens
qui part à ces monnaies sont arrêtés m'a
dit qu'est ce que vous faites
j'ai fait de saisir ce qui se passe les
gardiennes me dira non nous c'est les
offres de tousignant qu'on n'est pas sûr
de bien saisir alors que pour moi c'est
un peu la même chose c'est-à-dire il se
trouvait que l'accrochage était parfait
deux grands tableaux abstraits des
grandes plages noires dans lequel on
peut projeter tout dans lequel on peut
s'enfoncer dans qu'elles ont pu tirer
énormément d'informations ne serait ce
que parce qu'un nouveau nook ou ne
serait ce que par l'artiste nous laisse
la place dans sa manière de partager ce
qu'il a partagés je visais des ateliers
à tous les jours les ateliers d'artistes
je vais devant quelque chose que je ne
connais pas et mon métier cible sortir
pour le présenter à des gens comme vous
c'est mon métier
des gens tout le monde et il ya tous les
jours je suis placé devant quelque chose
que je ne connais pas donc je vais tirer
une leçon je tire un apprentissage et
j'espère qu'un jour ça va aussi vous
arriver et c'est vraiment tout le
bonheur que je vous souhaite